[MUSIC PLAYING]
We talk a lot about
the power of story.
You know, as tool and
technique for transformation,
for interpersonal persuasion.
To feel upgraded, to
experience catharsis.
How does it work, right?
When it works, it's
such a powerful thing.
I think stories are a kind
of cognitive technology.
They literally
colonize the brain.
They literally take over.
They pattern our ability to
discern the sense impressions
as the come in.
They are a deciphering mechanism
to abstract meaningful patterns
out of our lives.
And so stories are
so powerful, so
important is this tool, this
meta-pattern, that it plays out
again and again and again
in every single variation
and variable.
Joseph Campbell talks about
the hero with 1,000 faces.
It's always the same
hero because it's always
teaching us the same lesson.
It's always providing a map
to turn every experience
into a meaningful experience.
I almost feel that human beings
are embedded in their stories.
The human race-- who
we are-- is a story.
We are a narrative.
Mind is narrative.
Consciousness is a
self-reflecting awareness
of pattern, of story.
So I think it's innate.
We wouldn't be us without it.
It's a powerful thing.
It's a cathartic thing.
It's a thing worth
celebrating, worth framing,
and worth talking about,
distilling, dissecting,
exploring stories.
Hey guys, be sure to check
out The Dictionary of Obscure
Sorrows, which is literally
a compendium of words
we've never heard before used
to describe elusive feelings
that we can barely
ever articulate,
but we will surely recognize.
Check it out.